l'actualité vous l'avez mentionné
monsieur le Président c'est
effectivement la Coupe du monde
peut-être un certain nombre de chiffres
sur cette Coupe du monde
au total
en ligne et en dur c'est à dire dans les
points de vente FDJ
on aura presque
un peu plus de 900 millions d'euros qui
ont été parié
c'est un record absolu en ligne on
éteint 600 millions d'euros qui ont été
parié et ce sont des performances qui
sont beaucoup plus importantes que la
dernière Coupe du Monde ou même l'euro
les
matchs sont des matchs
qui ont permis à l'équipe de France
d'aller évidemment jusqu'à la finale et
la finale contre l'Argentine a permis 80
millions d'euros pariés là aussi c'est
un record il y a encore à ce stade
jamais eu de matchs qui ont enregistré
autant de Paris sur un seul match la
problématique qui était la nôtre c'est
d'essayer d'éviter que à l'occasion de
la Coupe du Monde se répète ce que nous
avions vu pendant l'Euro ce que nous
avions vu pendant l'Euro c'était une
surpression publicitaire extrêmement
forte qui avait ému nos concitoyens qui
avaient conduit un certain nombre
d'associations mais également de
parlementaires
de souhaiter que
la publicité sur les jeux d'argent soit
fortement restreinte en tout cas
il n'y avait pas eu à ce stade de
traduction législative ou réglementaire
mais on sent bien que l'opinion publique
c'était mobilisée face à cette
surpression publicitaire et donc
l'autorité nationale des jeux a mis en
place à la suite de l'euro tout un
dispositif pour cantonner la pression
publicitaire à l'occasion de la Coupe du
monde de football ce dispositif ce sont
des guidelines des lignes directrices
des recommandations sur le type d'outils
publicitaires sur le niveau des
gratifications et elle le plan d'action
de la engie c'est notamment traduit par
la signature en novembre 2022 de quatre
chartes qui ont pu mobiliser à la fois
les opérateurs de jeux d'argent tous les
opérateurs de jeux d'argent qui ont
signé ces chartes mais également les
supports Radio Télévision affichage
numérique qui ont également acceptés
finalement de policer leur pratique pour
réduire la pression publique la pression
publicitaire en faveur du jeu d'argent
la signature de ces quatre chartes et
certainement quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel en termes de corégulation
puisque je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de secteurs qui est pu se mettre autour
de la table avec l'ensemble des supports
publicitaires pour
se s'entendre sur une limitation de la
mobilisation de ces supports
au profit de leur propre annonces donc
là je crois que ça témoigne d'une prise
de conscience et des annonceurs et des
supports sur le fait que le jeu d'argent
n'est pas un produit comme les autres et
donc il convient pour la publicité de la
cantonnée de l'encadrer peut-être d'une
façon plus vigoureuse que ce qui était
pratiqué auparavant alors est-ce que ça
suffit pour la Coupe du monde de
football
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que de façon
globale la tonalité des messages pendant
la coupe du monde de football à
est rentré dans le champ de ce que
permet le décret de novembre 2020 c'est
à dire que les messages les plus
dithyrambiques et les plus
incitatifs à l'acte de jouer de parier
ont quasiment disparu
concernant le le montant global de la
publicité
c'est un peu difficile aujourd'hui de
vous en donner les conclusions
définitives nous avons lancé une
opération de contrôle sur les quatre
principaux opérateurs et nous aurons
d'ici quelques semaines vraiment les
chiffres et les campagnes publicitaires
qui ont été lancées leurs évaluations et
donc on sera capable de savoir si le
cantonnement publicitaire que nous avons
demandé à effectivement été respecté
mais d'après les premières analyses des
équipes de la engie il semblerait que ça
soit bien le cas
cela étant il y a au moins deux
questions qui restent ouvertes et qui ne
nécessiteront que la NJ s'intéresse à
ces questions dans les semaines à venir
c'est le sponsoring
on sent bien que
face à l'encadrement plus énergique par
le régulateur de la publicité les
opérateurs jeux d'argent ont fait un pas
de côté et on mobilisait les ressources
du sponsoring notamment la sponsoring
démission sportive ce qui fait que il
n'est pas
anormal que pendant un match vous ayez
presque 12
spots publicitaires
sur un match en faveur des jeux d'argent
là où normalement nous nous avons
cantonné à trois
dans chaque tunnel publicitaire donc on
voit bien que le sponsoring est un moyen
de contourner un petit peu la les
contraintes sur la publicité stricto
sensu et puis il y a un deuxième
phénomène qui est celui des influenceurs
les influenceurs ont été énormément
mobilisées par les opérateurs jeux
d'argent en fin d'année et je dirais que
c'est une tendance de fond du secteur
ces influenceurs vous savez que le
gouvernement est en train à lancer une
concertation sur les influenceurs pour
voir comment on pouvait mieux encadrer
la pratique des influenceurs qui dans
certains cas à donner lieu presque à des
fraudes qui ont été d'ailleurs dénoncés
par un DGCCRF nous nous travaillons avec
la DGCCRF sur la question des
influenceurs et nous avons fait
d'ailleurs des recommandations au
gouvernement concernant les jeux
d'argent et les influenceurs mais il est
certain que c'est un c'est une nouvelle
technique publicitaire qui est très
mobilisée par le secteur et qui a besoin
peut-être d'être un peu plus encadré
donc
ce que nous pensons c'est que
la pression publicitaire qui est un
sujet majeur pour le régulateur la
pression publicitaire reste forte
les mesures que nous avons prises ont
permis de cantonner celle-ci
jusqu'à un certain point mais
nous réfléchissons à la nécessité le cas
échéant de compléter notre arsenal
réglementaire parce que les dernières
études que nous avons côté de venus de
l'OFDT montre qu'il y aurait une
augmentation du taux de prévalence
c'est-à-dire du pourcentage du
pourcentage de joueurs problématique et
donc il est important que l'on puisse
s'adapter à ses nouvelles conclusions